court are everybody welcome to another
blab that's going to go on youtube as
well super excited to be joined by Andy
Paul from Andy Paul com Andy welcome
aboard Evan thank you very much Andy has
his website Andy Paul calm and runs a
podcast called the accelerate podcast
talking about how you can grow your
business through the lens of sales I let
him do a quick intro on that and Andy
reach out to me said hey I want to have
you on the podcast and say sure happy to
why don't we also turn that into a blab
and you took video for my audience to
kind of learn about what he's up to so
aim before kind of getting into the
podcast maybe or control the audience
sure I'm an author speaker I've got two
books published both amazon best sellers
one called zero times selling one called
amp up your sales and all about how to
accelerate sayadi saw with value how do
you become a service provider to your
customer and bog and author he said you
find my my blog at Andy Paul calm also
linked in have a large following on
linkedin that's my content there and
then the podcast is relatively recent
tired in October and it's growing really
nicely and being recognized as on the
top sales blogs already five days a week
30 minute unscripted interviews sort of
like we're gonna do here today and all
about sale sales management leadership
marketing yeah because Jim doesn't
happen without marketing branding like
I'll talk about today anything that
helps companies get a better perspective
on how to grow their revenues quickly
cool well that's it awesome sure when
take it away let's do it alright well
hey thanks for joining me here today as
everybody knows you're havin Carmichael
for the people are listening after the
fact my guest to Evan Carmichael blog or
entrepreneur supporter of entrepreneurs
a great way crates and curates a ton of
valuable information every day it's
practical it's useful it's inspirational
motivational and I think as particular
genius as how he presents this
information for the reader to make it
easy to consume so Evan welcome to the
show thanks man I appreciate that intro
I want to bring you everywhere with me
now okay yeah for a small fee we can
arrange that but so take a minute or
fill out the introduction
where'd you come from what you know
where you start how did you get to where
you are today sure growing up I thought
I want to be a banker my high school
yearbook says we're going to be in ten
years was VP at a bank that's where I
thought I was going to be didn't have
any entrepreneurial kind of influences
in my life and the University connected
with two entrepreneurs and had one of
the toughest decisions ever in my life
basically deciding between taking the 80
to 100 thousand dollar jobs at the
investment bank so I thought I always
wanted to do versus starting the
business and making three hundred
dollars a month and eaten brians for
lunch every day and struggling um so I
made that tough choice and became an
entrepreneur and and had some success
with that company well what was that
company doing it was biotech software
there were two partners who had started
the company i joined as a third owner
and my job was in the business side of
things they wanted to cut code and put
out great software they had the company
for a little while and just wasn't
taking off and I joined to help help
sell help get biz dev going up getting
the media helped build a brand and in
three years we went from you know living
below the poverty line to happening nasa
and johnson johnson and customers in 30
countries and and being acquired and
then I left that when did the venture
capital barbat throw so before we going
on and what what did you do how did you
help him get get customers so quickly so
at the start I sucked we all do no one
scenario sure I didn't have a plan it
just felt like I'm a I'm in business so
I you know studying business at school I
can I can do this and I tried everything
I could think of and just basically
failed and and told my partner I quit
and that was maybe the worst day of my
life and then I realized that I had to
find a different way to do and then I
wasn't the first guy to try to figure
this out and the one thing that really
saved me was modeling success and you
talked to some of the videos and stuff
that I do now it's still the same theme
of modeling people who've done greater
things and I haven't made guess for your
show to having people on and sharing
their success right for me my first
model was Bill Gates and I'm hits all
the software company I'm not the first
guy to try to sell software before
somebody's figured this out
why stop beating my head against the
wall and so I looked at Bill Gates and
how he got microsoft from 0 to 1 million
I didn't care about how he makes extra
million now but like 0 to y how do I do
that that's what I want to do right hey
through I was for him was to
partnerships and their big deal was with
IBM where every IBM soul and Microsoft's
offer on it but I Microsoft was already
a seven million dollar company when that
deal added so that's not a huge company
but it's still seven million more than I
was like how do I get to that to that
first seven million and and it was again
through partnerships yeah so they would
always find ways to partner and even as
answered in new markets you know expedia
was a partnership with American Express
they kept partnering up and so I thought
okay well how can I apply that to my
business and I started looking for
partners are presenting us first in
international countries because you know
somebody would wanted to download us off
when Japan I don't speak Japanese I
don't understand the business culture
the time zones all my stuff so let's
let's partner with something to sell it
for us right I'm the first deal that I
closed was in Europe and I brought me 13
and a half thousand dollars up front and
that may not sound like a lot of money
but I make a few Nadal's a month you
know that was like that was I was
cheering man that was I was crying I was
so happy and more importantly gave me a
recipe to then follow again and again
again replicated yeah learning learning
to build your business off your
customers money is a good way to do it
right and so I kept I kept partnering up
with different people forming an
international distributor network to
represent our brand and our software
then at the same time establishing my
partner as a thought leader and getting
him recognized in the media getting him
a reviews been him exposure sighs was my
worst subject you know so I drop size in
high school as soon as I could so I
didn't really understand the technical
level what are softer did I could
explain it in like high level but not I
couldn't get into the science of it and
so my job was partly to then expose my
partner as this leader this expert and
get him featured because you can get a
lot more sales out of you know being
having a cover story talking about you
as opposed to hang up on an ad and so
those two things were the main things
that I focused on how do I get media how
do I raise awareness
we how many people that know us and the
people behind and then we talk on
personal branding so that might help all
right and then establishing the
distribution network getting partners
realize we have to do this one one one
one at a time you know media is not like
it's finding ways how can we reach
thousands of people at a time instead of
one-offs all the time right how explode
business and yeah and figures you know
got acquired and moved on the other
things so how did you get from there to
where you are today so we sold the
business my two partners went with the
business they were the technical you
know back end and they needed to
integrate with the company plus they had
a personal ambition to move to the US
and the company by masala for Nia so
they took off um I wanted to see here
that need to go to California from
Caliban oh man I love Toronto Toronto my
home this is where I am you know I I I
wanted to stay and and they're also
wasn't a major need for me because they
the company that bought us whether they
were going to use everything internally
they didn't need this dev anymore which
is great so the matched up for everybody
I was in a fortunate position of you
know I didn't have to go I didn't make
like stupid money but I made enough that
I didn't have to worry about things for
a while and for a why was the little
depressed and that I don't know what to
do next but always in ever yeah hook up
with a venture capital company here in
Toronto I was always curious about
raising capital we thought about it in
our venture we never had to we got it we
kind of got acquired before we needed to
go raising money but it was interesting
for me and I wanted to learn how that
works so I connected with a venture
capital company here in Toronto and the
the three founding partners were all in
their 60s or 70s have an insane amount
of experience that they imparted on me
model for them was to help bring in the
same role basically help bring in new
business right there they knew the
investors but they weren't in tune you
know means either older maybe that just
in care as much they were to help the
younger right so that was my role is to
do biz dev I you know strike up
conversations get people interested in
in us as a venture capital opportunity
and
that was interesting for a while the
same time i started my website Evan
Carmichael calm I used it as a platform
to share my story as well as raise
awareness for venture capital as a
result of selling my company I was 22
when I sold my company so I had a lot of
people ask me to come do speaking
engagements and a bunch of this stuff so
the website was more personal site at
the start just hey I'm speaking in
Malaysia and hang on speaking in
wherever and then started using it as a
way to build up content around the
venture capital business as my website
sort of taking off and getting more
realize hey this could be a business
opportunity in itself I felt like I had
learned what I wanted to learn about the
venture capital business and it wasn't
something that I wanted to be in full
time and so I started doing my website
of helping entrepreneurs and taking that
idea of Marlon success what really
helped me learn from bill gates that
saved my business even though I never
met bill to apply that to my company I
want to then do that again and again and
again learn from lots of different
famous entrepreneurs and built up the
site then have the largest collection of
famous entrepreneur stories and you are
online and then that has transitioned to
my youtube channel where you've
mentioned the videos and every day we
release content that's a mix of my
thoughts as well as lessons from Fisk
entrepreneurs where instead of having to
watch you know 40 hours of your lawn
musk videos to pulled out nuggets he
will be like a 15 minute video of all of
his best stuff and to release right this
top 10 top 10 rules his best advice that
at least is seen through my filter to
sing through my eyes of what I think is
helpful relevant valuable and I've kind
of become a curator of content as well
as share my own opinions and thoughts to
help entrepreneurs grow perfect well I
said I'm visit your site and read the
content you know the top 10 list i love
i love that the inspirational cause i
think that's great you've got this great
mix of things in there but I'm it made
me think about a particular challenge
for salespeople these tables so just you
know personal branding right because him
customers are being inundated with
undifferentiated messages coming from
your automated automated sales mushy
sales emails that they're sending out
using all the latest tools and so
branding really becomes an important
topics you know because once the
customer gets something and maybe if
their tree by the email they're going to
go somebody's linkedin profile or
twitter profile or something and see
okay who is this person what do they
stand for what do they do so yeah you're
a few our sales run you've been in
business for a while so what are the
steps you need to take to start building
this trusted advisor status yeah I think
it's super important for salespeople
because the salesperson has to has to
evolve or will die you know the
salesperson has to understand how to
build the brand how to add value beyond
just trying to sell your product and
meet a quota but like I think it what's
that like like everybody else I'm sing
about so what do you do this [ __ ]
doesn't drop and so so it starts with
understanding what you stand for as the
human being forget about what you're
selling at the moment what are you
staying for is a human being what's the
most important thing to you in your life
what's the biggest impact that you want
to have on the world and that might
sound kind of Airy fairy fluffy soft you
know but it's important you know what
motivates you to get up every day and go
make a contribution because if you're
the kind of sales person is just working
for a paycheck you're never going to be
a super successful salesperson you have
to want to do something bigger yes let's
break that down for a second because
this is certainly people talk about it
but it seems like step people really
have a hard time with so I mean how did
you go through that and what were the
steps you would recommend somebody do to
not just get it down on paper but then
yeah bounce it off people make sure it
real right so for me my I believe
everybody has one word that identifies
who the yarn and their their their core
message Jimmy's believe you know it's on
my walls I'm like it's in all the videos
it's the core message that i sent
through every piece of content that i
create it's the way in which i see the
world i believe in people and
specifically entrepreneurs because i
have the skill set to be able to help
entrepreneurs I can't believe in you as
a person and you know you can go off me
a great horse racer but I don't know
anyone horses so I can give you tactical
device to help you get to where you are
so it comes down to what your core value
is as a human being as a
like forget about your business right
now and a lot of businesses talk about
values but how many you know even CEOs
of a business could list off the 20 core
values that they have when who aren't
living revives so as a human being what
is what is most important to you you
know maybe Trust is really important
maybe Trust is your thing like this is
what I staying for is a human being then
when you get into tactical how do I sell
your selling trust you know whoever you
are depends on what product you're
selling sushi finally insurance has exam
right trust please are you Joel in that
if you're selling cars then you're the
you're the trusted guy to work with in
the car industry it doesn't everything
yourself trust was like a photo it could
be but but believe is too I could be the
relief card sales guy could be I could
be the the comms car sales guy right you
know whatever the value is that you you
hold most dear to you right that's what
you want to funnel through all of your
sales and marketing and advantages and
often that can fit within a typical sale
structure like you're off selling
whatever product it can typically fit
sometimes it doesn't and that may be a
situation where you earn the wrong
company you have to move to one where
you're selling stuff that does fit more
congruently with who you are as a human
being yeah and I think that one of the
things i would recommend when people do
that is to still take some time by
themselves turn off the TV turn off the
cell phone transfer distractions really
think about this in terms of you know
write down five things do you think that
really motivates you that you really
believe in to use your your word but
then bounce it off a couple people right
ask my people does this fit with what
you think I'm doing because I I find
people really have a hard time
understanding we are and how they come
across and how people perceive them
which is part of this still part of this
whole struggle yeah suffered for me my
take on that is I think I think a lot of
people aren't very self-aware I think
some people are when I people to come up
with the one core value that represents
who you are some people like think they
know that they got at no problem I
wasn't like that it took a long time to
kind of narrow it down and i would
suggest spending more time with yourself
as opposed to other people I think off
we show like inside of ourselves to
people you should I side of yourself to
your wife aside of yourself to your
friends inside yourself to your boss and
we we play into their expectations your
boss wants you to be a certain way so
you act like that your wife wants you to
be certain ways you act like that and
and there are very few people who
actually know you for who you are where
you're truly naked in front of them very
few people and so when you're coming up
with what is called you you want to look
inwards much more than living up to
somebody else's expectation of you
that's never going to be the right thing
right and so how how I find it easy to
explain keep on guide people through the
process is think about not just who you
are now but who you've always been and
who you always will be think about what
your favorite book is your favorite
movie think about your favorite
professor in school if your mayor think
about why you love your husband or wife
like what there's a common theme
connecting everything together for me my
favorite moves Seabiscuit I know if you
know it's what I seem like 30 times well
it's a super cheesy movie I cried your
aunt I you're supposed to about believe
right the you know there's a racehorse
that nobody believes in the jockey new
believes in an order nobody believes and
they all band together somehow make this
thing happen and that I just love and uh
you know when my when I was growing up
my parents always told me I was a kiss
truly karma coming mom's last names it's
truly and I could do anything Amy and I
try to continue that tradition to my son
to say hey didn't you know you're hating
karma you can do anything and and you
know they've never been only give me
kind of practical information on how to
grow a business because entrepreneurship
is not their skill they made me myself
so this is something that it's a
constant your life it's not a new year's
resolution at this year I want to be
more grateful or whatever it is it's
something who you actually are and right
always have been and always will be
that's why it's a core value and the
more you can tie into that right you
know I attract people who love belief
and you hate it my god stupid believe
you know and that's great they self
eliminate right if you're selling your
like you can't sell to everybody but you
need a way to differentiate yourself and
stand out
ok you know so as an example i run a
salsa dance company here it's an
investment that i need and recently
acquired this business so I familiy know
a business selling salsa classes right
we don't sell salsa we don't sell dis
ting we sell family right they'll
community we sell fun so it's not about
learning how to be the best dancer it's
about coming and this is the best part
of your week because you have a life
that you hate and you have no friends
and you're coming out and this is like
you hate your boss is the best day of
your week and so understanding that is
why it's the biggest salsa dancing
school in North America because most
people are selling the steps and here
you can be a great dancer most people
can we don't want to be a great dancer
they're just looking for an escape from
their life having fun right and that's
what we saw we sell the community we
sell the family and so understanding
that lets us become the biggest in the
industry so not everybody wants to be
part of the family great like those
people will never sign up for our school
and so it's understanding who you are as
a person and then bringing that through
in all of your messaging so that if
somebody does value the same thing that
you do if somebody does value trust as
their number one thing and that's who
you are then they're going to come to
you by default as you work with with
clients who get what you're all about
who you're going to have a great
connection with because you have the
same core value who's going to buy more
from you refer more from you you know
you move on to something else they're
going to follow you to that too because
they believe what you're doing where if
you're just another guy trying to sell
car insurance or whatever it is you're
one of many and you're not staying out
and so I'm just going to compete on
price it's like if I can't tell the
difference between you and somebody else
I'm just okay who's cheaper yeah give me
reason to care or if you can't give me
the reason to care we're not gonna buy
anything right now we'll come back when
we need somebody who does give us a
reason to care so which is he on sales
the studies coming out saying that sixty
percent of qualified opportunities in
the pipeline the business the business
world go to no decision right because no
one's given the reason to care so so
once you've got that core belief then
how do you start translating that into a
public persona you know this you're
going to use own people also zoom on
your LinkedIn profile Twitter profile
wherever what's the first steps you
recommend people take the first step is
coming up with your foundation story
so tell me why this is so important to
you tell me why you care so much about
this on your website there needs to be
your story your picture I mean ideally a
video if you can get in front of a
camera says people you know have a
higher ability to be able to do that
then maybe more introverted people who
aren't great at sales but tell me your
story because so many people hide behind
a corporate website and then again your
vanilla you're boring I don't care about
you this is especially is relevant to
the more entrepreneurial kinds of the
more kinds of salespeople where you have
some control you can create your own
website you can create your own present
you can decide what goes on the Flyers
that gets sent out but even in think
about what's what's on your voicemail
you know what's the message when people
call you up what's on the voicemail
what's on your LinkedIn profile what's
your twitter profile what kind of
content are you producing and sharing
you know if I'm if I'm a sales person
selling trust my content should be about
trust mm-hm and I should be attracting
people who like a trusted message even
if it has nothing to do with buying
whatever product that you're selling and
when they're ready to buy you're going
to be the first guy to come to because
they're already liking your stuff and
coming to you anyway a lot of people who
follow my stuff aren't entrepreneurs I
don't want to be a better right I just
love the message of belief right and if
they ever do decide to become
entrepreneurs or they know friends who
are entrepreneurs they were going to
share my stuff and that's what you want
you want to be producing stuff through
your bio through videos through social
media through websites to interviews
with the media that is appeal that
appeals to people who aren't just
potential customers but could refer
customers on to you because they love
your message alright so a basic sales
person though isn't I sit down and write
a blog probably right so so how do they
you know what do you recommend for them
in terms of how they go out and begin
less you did to curate really
interesting content ok they've
identified what their core belief is how
they can do that I mean the thought that
a salespersons i'm just going to write
down and sit down the block well maybe
they should you know everybody should be
a famous shouldn't but i'm just telling
you what the reality is right right well
i mean and the reality is the guys who
don't may not have a sales job you know
like if you are not
producing content or to reading or
sharing it's going to be hard to stand
out right so if you are whether it's
sitting down the running of like some
guys may not be great writing if you're
not great at writing don't start writing
blog posts right get on video if you're
if you're much better off the cuff and
talking to people and and like I i'll be
on video so i suggested doing this as a
video you know i love being on video it
matches book for my audiences and also
what I'm not really good at and want to
get better at right and so it's picking
a medium that fits best for you so if
you're you know if you're a pure sales
person against the link trust whatever
product it is that you're selling I
would love to see you come out and
create a foundational video that tells
your story why trust is so important to
you like what does it mean to you really
not not some like dress is really
important and it's the backbone about
you know like the best stuff like but
get emotional right is it does it come
from your mom does it come from your
kids like I want to feel the passion and
the deep connection to that word because
if I feel the same way man you got me
sold I don't care how much you're you're
charged and i'll pay more to go with you
right um here's an example a guy called
in to my radio show selling landscaping
services uh-huh he's like I'm being
undercut by by kids who can mow lawns
for five bucks like I'm not going to do
that how do i how do i send em compete
as well you haven't given people a
reason like if i compare you to the high
school kid why am I going to go with you
what's how are you different if I can't
understand that his high school kid
every day of the week it's five bucks or
says you're 50 bucks right he's a
decision and I asked him why he started
this business and he said it was because
when he grew up his mom really cared
about lawns and take care of the garden
he would help her every day and that was
his connection to her and every time he
goes to a customer's house he treats
their lawn like it's his mother's line
mm-hmm I'm him telling that story it
makes me feel like this guy cares right
and it's not the high school kid might
make a mess and might step on my flowers
and might you know not really care but
this guy feel like it was going to care
and i will pay more to work with him
because he told me his story and it's
much more than just
the features that you're selling in the
back points right those are important
but if you can sell it the core level if
you can connect with me on an emotional
level first then I'm much more likely to
buy from you and be less sensitive to
pricing this price it's always going to
be an issue but if you can't make me
feel emotional then it's going to be the
most important issue which you never
want to get it okay so let me ask you a
question in the context of really want
the toughest challenge of sales reps
apps today increasingly in such the
technology business you know sales is
being specialized or inside sales reps
whose job is purely just to get somebody
to agree for the next meeting so they're
the ones sending out this emails and
making phone calls 50 phone calls a day
and so on how do they do that okay they
work their LinkedIn profile and so and
so forth but when they get that person
that first person on the phone the first
time or what's in that email message
that they need to be able to say to
capture the attention of somebody based
around their core value and you're
talking about like I'm just giving this
list of people that I need to call up on
them every headquarters yeah yeah i
would i would if we don't have anything
tied to that individual like more you
can customize it based on knowledge
about that person that they have kids
interest whatever the better yep can't
do that then I would tighten to what I
feel is a match between my core value
and the company's core value like what
this business is trying to accomplish
and leading that so I want to leave the
something I can feel personally
connected to an attached to huh but I
need to put in the context of the
company as well because they have some
kind of interest in the company because
they've expressed an interest right they
sign up to download something I would
ever the round my list somehow and so I
try to tie that to the business somehow
and it's it's as in all sales is going
to be a numbers game where you're not
going to hit everybody with a message
that if you try to hit everybody it's
going to be a vanilla boring message
that won't connect with anybody right
right right so you could give it is a
problem is it's also not like you know
the message that I put out is appealing
to some people and it's not appealing to
others and what's fun and so you can
give that same list to three different
sales people and make it each attack it
in different ways and each get
different customers based on how to
attacking it if we all attack it in the
same way it's going to be born vanilla
and it's the only people are going to
get are the ones who just really need a
solution and we happen to be there at
the right time right and that sales is
about timing that has to be a need there
has to be a project you know they have
to have the budget and and you just
being there magically at the right
moment that's a lot of the sales too and
so anybody can pick those up just by
being persistent and writing there at
the right time the other ones the market
value based relationship based my goal
is I want to get a customer to then
wants to stay with me for life who loves
what I representing them all about who
then will refer tons of clients to me
too because those guys who just nothin
need it on that spot moment they're
often not the best long-term clients
because you still need to build a
relationship with them and you may not
share similar values and there are
clients that you get that you connect
really well with another zet like you
struggle with them and just don't get it
and and they may be a big fit for
another salesperson who let's fit them
really well so I would be uh infusing so
if it were me I would be infusing my
message with believe so I'd be talking
about how much I believe in them and
what they're trying to do or if I don't
have that information how much I believe
what my company I wanna do or whatever
better promise a better future I can
create for my client that's what I would
I that's what I would try to do to do
with the belief you might put it with
trust and the other guy might put it
with peace of mind or the other guy
throw it with calm and the other you
know like just infuse it with your own
style provided that you have the freedom
because a lot of times you even have the
ability to edit those emails it just
goes out and somebody is what counting
in you know well they run and how much
they want you to personalize them but
you have to at the time and you have to
know what you're going to personalize
with us you said so right and so like
you could have it out you can include a
link can you include a link out to your
website that shows why you care so much
about this like why this really means
something is especially for us is good
on video an email can be hard to get
your message across so link out to video
where you are passionately talking about
what you
you and why I mean so much to you is
awesome right like put that in send it
off and that helps build a personal
connection I have a lot of people who
write into me or who recognize me in the
street or send me messages and they feel
like they know me even though I have no
idea who they are yes Oh glue but
they're reciting stories that I'm
tallying they feel like they know me and
that's sharing authentically and and
talking about my stories I've shared a
lot on the YouTube channel about
personal struggles and what I'm going
through at the moment when I've had to
go through and by sharing that it builds
trust and people feel like they know me
like me want to do business with me and
so that's what ideally any sales person
is doing as well you know you start with
your foundation story whether zaggy or a
blog post or her you want to put it up
and then you're creating consistent
content that you can lead people to and
ideally ideally gets a point where you
are attracting people to your business
or to your you know to call you so you
don't need a Rolodex comic but i'm out
like this right because you're producing
is so much gold content is the new
marketing that people come in and they
want to work with you yep okay perfect
so great information great information
for the audience for people listening to
show sales reps sales managers
entrepreneurs so now we're going last
segment on my show I've got some
standard questions asked all my guests
let's do it let's do it so first
question is hypothetical scenario you've
just been hired as the new sales leader
at a company whose sales are completely
stalled out and senior management really
wants to get unstuck in a hearse so what
two things would you do your first week
on the job that could have the biggest
impact I would come back to figure out
what we stand for as a company and then
I would create an epic piece of content
that people want to share that that
wasn't just advertising but that I got
value by looking at that piece of
marketing whether it's my video or an ad
or a story that promotes my business but
I get value by looking at it and reading
it excellent a great answer although all
right
rapid fire questions you give me one
word answer so you can elaborate if you
wish first one is when you personally
are selling what's your strong sales
asset I think I know the answer but give
it to me anyway loot man Bolivia I she
fired a back fire its fire alright so so
who's your business role model I have a
number of them I think my parents
started me off and more so in terms of
just values had a cheap people being
nice how to be human being Bill Gates
became my first business role model my
favorite entrepreneur is AP Giannini who
was the background or bank of america
most people think of Denker I was a
banker your favorite entrepreneur but
you know he bet on Walt Disney when
nobody believed in it he bet on the
little guy he gave out loans based on a
handshake and a look in somebody's I you
know who imagine a banker saying hey
give me a loan I look at my eye on a
handshake that's not happening so he was
the belief banker uh and from there lots
of people like I look up to I think you
can pull from everybody I think I could
pull from Donald Trump you can pull from
Kanye where you can pull from bill gates
and you may not like everything that
they stand for as a human being but
there's one thing in them that can help
you and the goal is not to be Donald
Trump but to be the best version of
yourself and you can learn something
from him to get there okay so along the
same lines what's the one book
entrepreneurship read ah my favorite
book while my favorite book is probably
the the 4-hour workweek in Ferris that
that shaped a lot of my thoughts on time
management and delegating and that
helped me a certain point in my business
my second favorite book is called
radicals and visionaries and it's not in
print anymore but you may be to find
that old copy of it it's basically as
put my entrepreneur press and it shows
the stories of famous entrepreneurs in
like three or four pages every morning I
would just read a different stories kind
of before you two days I'd read a story
and just get inspired to have an
environment where I felt like these
people were around me and I'm like I'm
sitting in the room with Martha Stewart
for 10 minutes and it just made me break
out on my comfort zone to try and make
more
confidence all right there's tough
question 1 what's your favorite music on
your playlist this is favorite music on
my playlist I should look I have a
belief coolest mom song that i just
added was super old pool was back of the
bus Pete's younger you'd figure yeah
yeah it's and I got in the fight with
somebody cuz they said it was kind of
like Rafi like this is a revolutionary
song man Rafi killing me man this I'm
not explain the lyrics that's with what
all this meant like you have this white
guy standing up for black people right
on an error that's not cool and and then
just I have mad respect for pc guy yeah
guys I mean Emma and a bunch of a bunch
of songs but that wasn't one of the most
recent ones that I had it all right
we've got kids so maybe you have Raffy
on there as well no no hate unhappy no
hate unhappy but not he'd see oh come on
man oh my kids were young I there's a
Rafi song that was stuck in my head for
months at 88 little piggies or eight
piggies in a row it was don't don't get
it second my hand painting so what's the
first sales activity you do every day I
I review the comments on my youtube
video because my community is my sales
tool I respond I'm the only youtuber of
my size that I know of that still has it
once every single comment myself with
team I've scaled the people who work on
my team to respond to youtube comments
right because the community helps foster
growth right I just by saying thank you
acknowledging them and listening to them
that creates activity and buzz momentum
and word-of-mouth and referral so it's
not the sales isn't hey can you please
share this or buy from me now and for
the sales people kind of listening to
this all of those interactions or should
be daily should be reaching out to the
people who you pout than the people in
your community and just being an asset
without trying to sell anything because
if they see you as that asset they're
going to come back when you have an
opportunity for you and refer you and
always be thinking that you always want
to stay top of mind that's how you get
the sales magnets
every day you should start by doing
things to help somebody else excellent
all right well I want to thank you for
being on my show Evan and for people and
find out more about you I know your
audience can they're watching but for
people in my audience how can they find
out more about you how much is google
Evan Carmichael my website will show up
youtube channel Twitter whatever
whatever your fancy is I'm there all
right excellent okay remember friends
who are listening on those my show make
sure make a part of your day every day
to deliberately learn something new help
you accelerate success it don't miss
great conversations well like i had when
i have my guest today i have a
Carmichael who gave us his expertise
about how to grow your business more
quickly so Evan thank you very much and
everybody else have a great day thanks
Andy all right does good man hey that's
fun I loved it yeah so is this a daily
podcast you put in five days a week wow
that's a lot of work yes but a lot of
fun yeah I am learning so much I love it
I love it I cool and then I guess
everybody watching them i'll put the
link in the description but you can go
check out Andy Paul calm call the
accelerate podcast and this is going to
air when Andy huh probably about 60 days
oh wow 60 days that's a wrong production
schedule well we yeah we record quite a
ways in advance so we're yeah we're
basically filling out a second quarter
as we speak Wow okay cool well you know
what let me know when it's out and then
I'll also do it I'll care to and let
people know because they may not
remember to check their counter in 60
days for well like eyes with this and
we'll share this in a dance and we'll
get that out there promote back out of
it poof perfect well I know we're a
little bit over but thanks to time and
you hopefully that helped and really
fishing okay yeah we'll talk to you soon
cool cheers again but